la ville de paris mise en examen dans la
sphère de l'explosion de la rue de
trévise les faits remontent au 12
janvier 2019
à l'époque une fuite de gaz avait fait
quatre morts dont deux pompiers 66
blessés
les experts ont souligné de nombreux
manquements de la part de la
municipalité parisienne
le ca de la copropriété de l'immeuble
détruit et a lui aussi été mises en
examen et pour en parler nous sommes
avec olivier morice avocat de plusieurs
familles de victimes
c'est maurice bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors les
experts expliquent que cette tragédie
aurait pu être évitée si la ville de
paris avait anticipé plus d'un an et
demi après l'accident qui est il
aujourd'hui reproché à la municipalité
il est reproché des manquements graves
vous avez raison de dire que les experts
ont conclu en disant que ce drame aurait
pu être évité si la ville de paris avait
rempli ses obligations et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les juges
d'instruction qui ont été désignés pour
instruire ce dossier ont décidé la
semaine dernière de passer une étape
supplémentaire et un tournant à notre
sens en mettant en examen la ville de
paris pour ses manquements qui sont
graves et qui ont conduit à la tragédie
que nous connaissons aucun risque
concrètement la ville de paris alors la
ville de paris risquent des
condamnations pécuniaires importante il
faut savoir aujourd'hui que il semble
par l'intermédiaire de leurs conseils
que la ville de paris est indiqué qu'il
entendait contester les conclusions de
ce rapport d expertise et de rentrer
dans une logique d'une procédure qui
probablement risque de durer un certain
nombre d'années
malgré la diligence des juges
d'instruction et c'est un point que nous
regrettons parce que jusqu'à présent la
ville de paris a essayé de jouer une
certaine communication avec tous ceux
qui étaient blessés ou sinistrés dans
cette tragédie en expliquant qu'elle
n'assumerait entièrement ses
responsables
inité et bien maintenant il est temps de
le faire puisque cette mise en examen
est un tournant important et signifie
que des éléments graves sont reprochés à
la ville de paris dans la survenance de
cette tragédie
alors le syndic de l'immeuble a
également été mis en cause qui a la plus
grande part de la responsabilité entre
le syndicat et la ville de paris
je partais stablement c'est la ville de
paris qui a une part de responsabilité
la plus importante dans ce dossier
encore une fois il faut maintenant que
la vie de paris ou que tous ceux qui
sont chargés d'encadrer les sinistrés
dans cette tragédie ne puisse assumer
leurs responsabilités je pense notamment
à la maire du 9e arrondissement qui est
assez dynamique
dans le cadre de propositions qui
doivent être faites nous attendons
maintenant que des propositions avance
mais nous regrettons très franchement la
communication de la ville de paris qui
semble se draper dans le déni alors
qu'elle devrait assumer pleinement ses
responsabilités
vous enlevez que demandaient les
victimes de ce drame que l'indemnisation
est beaucoup plus rapidement que ceux
qui ne se déroule qu'on prenne en
considération l'ensemble de leur
préjudice non seulement des préjudices
qui sont des préjudices moraux des
préjudices des dommages matériels
certains blessés qui sont encore
traumatisés par ce qui s'est déroulé ce
que les parties civiles que je
représente demande c'est que la justice
puisse aller vite mais pour cela il faut
aussi que la ville de paris coopèrent et
ne sera pas dans une forme de déni
qu'une regrettons aujourd'hui je pense
que nous ne sommes pas à un stade où il
faut que la ville rentrer dans une
polémique quant à sa responsabilité mais
au contraire qu'elle puisse l'assumé
pleinement
alors dernière question à m à mauressac
la ville de paris a lancé une contre
expertise car elle estime que les
services de voirie ont assuré leurs
travaux quelles pourraient être les
recours possibles
alors ce n'est pas la ville de paris qui
est un alors je dirais manoeuvre pour
solliciter une contre expertise
ils peuvent éventuellement faire une
demande d'acte au magistrat instructeur
afin que cette contre expertise soit
désigné mais il faut savoir et encore
une fois nous regrettons qu'une démarche
de contre-expertise risque de durer
encore très longtemps que les experts ou
que des nouveaux experts risque de
prendre des mois pour faire leur travail
et des familles ne souhaitent pas
attendre tout ce temps qui est
extrêmement lourd pour elle je que je
crois qu'il faut très franchement qu'au
sein de la ville de paris il y ait des
responsables qui assume les conséquences
de cet acte qui encore une fois est une
tragédie est ce que nous espérons aussi
c'est que la voirie de paris soit mieux
entretenu parce que potentiellement des
risques de survenance d'une telle
tragédie
et bien ne sont pas je dirais à négliger
merci beaucoup maître olivier morice
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes ses avocats de
ces familles de victimes du drame de la
rue de trévise